- Hi, I'm Michelle, and the
first time I saw porn was,
oh, he's convincing her to,
(gasps)
not that long ago.
Today, I'm gonna be spending the day
with a porn star.
What intrigues me a lot about
the adult film industry,
and porn stars in general,
is that their line of
work is sharing something
that is so private,
yet their normal life
is completely unknown
to the public.
So, I'm really interested
to see what is actually
her private life.
- Hi.
- [Michelle] Hi!
Nice to meet you.
- [Mia] Nice to meet you,
welcome to my little cottage.
The ukulele's, I have seven of them,
these are two of them.
This one is Vinny, he's
a concert sized uke,
and that one's Chibs,
which is my acoustic
electric that plugs in.
♫ Sweet dear
♫ Your my mac and cheese
♫ I could eat you each day ♫
- [Michelle] How long have
you been rock climbing?
- I've been rock climbing for about,
five, six years.
- [Michelle] Wow.
- [Mia] Yeah.
- [Michelle] Okay, Mia has really,
really kindly offered to
take me, I'm gonna be a complete noob,
but we'll see how it goes.
- We'll make sure you're safe,
- [Michelle] Okay.
- That's the only important part.
I've been in adult film
for almost three years.
- How did you get started?
- Well, I have always
been a very sexual person,
and at that point of my life,
I was exploring being queer,
and polyamory and open relationships,
and swinging,
and someone had said off hand like,
"Hey, you should do porn."
So I went on Craigslist of all things,
I was like, okay, I'm
gonna get a feel for this,
and see what I can do, make
decisions based on that.
I felt like I was in the
career that was meant
for me, it felt like
the community that I've
been waiting for, that's
super sex positive
and mindful and smart.
- Kay, so we are here, in San Diego.
About to boulder this rock.
Which means we're rock
climbing without ropes.
- There are definitely things you learn,
like opening up to the
camera, finding your light,
making sure your hair isn't covering
your face while you're sucking a cock.
- [Michelle] Are you
ever like, self conscious
on camera?
- Absolutely, but I try
not to focus on that,
when I am on.
Yay, rock climb.
- So, go up this way?
What was it like telling
your friends and family,
that you were doing this?
Or do they not know?
- My community in San Diego, I'm out.
So my family members know.
Definitely a hard thing
to talk about with my
family, because I had no sexual education
from my parents, other than don't do it.
- [Michelle] I'm from a
really conservative town,
like, very religious.
- Yeah, oh my God, do you watch porn now?
- I mean, sometimes.
(laughs)
- Yay!
- [Michelle] I feel like
I grew up, and I obviously
knew what masturbation
was, but I just thought
it was a thing that guys did.
I just thought like, wow.
I've been relying on guys to do this for
so many years,
and now I don't feel
like I have to have that.
And that was really empowering.
Oh my God!
- [Mia] You got it!
Yay!
Do you want a picture up there?
- Yes.
Have you ever felt
uncomfortable during a scene?
- Certainly, and that's why
safe words are in place.
To make sure that line
of communication is open,
to make sure that those
uncomfortable moments
are just moments of adjustment,
and not necessarily
something from a malicious
place.
Horrible people do exist,
the majority of the
people in the industry,
and the people that I've encountered,
are there because we love our profession,
and we respect each other well enough to
understand everything about consent,
and make sure that all
the acts that we do,
are consented by and that
we're having a good time,
because that's what makes good content.
There we go.
- This is where you cam?
- This is one of the places that I cam.
- One of the places.
- Yeah.
- Can you show, like,
- [Mia] Some tips?
- Teach me how to do this.
- Okay.
- If I were to cam.
- So pretend that's the webcam right?
Okay, I'll pose my body,
so I can show like,
enough skin,
and like look really curvy,
like 'cause I have those sometimes.
And like prop myself up on my elbow.
Or if I want, I can
like tighten the frame,
so it's like from my hips up
and I can sit comfortably like this
for a longer period of time.
I like glass butt plugs,
and glass toys,
because you can make them really cold.
- [Michelle] What is this?
- [Mia] A butt plug.
- Oh.
- This is really fun,
because if the tails out,
I can like tug on the tail and like
stimulate my butt hole
when it's in my butt.
- Oh.
- I have stuff in my mouth,
I have like butt plug fur.
That's the danger of furry butt plugs.
- Which ones your favorite?
- This guy, I love this guy.
- [Michelle] That one's the prettiest.
Have you ever like, faked,
- [Mia] Orgasms?
- Faked orgasms?
- Yeah, yeah.
'Cause not everything,
some people are like,
"I want it this way super hard,
at this speed, faster,
harder, in five seconds.
Cum for me right now."
I'm like, okay, this person doesn't know
how orgasms work.
And they're just like,
making a lot of demands,
and I like, set my boundaries,
because that's what sex work is all about,
setting your boundaries
and sticking to them.
Be like, this is about me sweetie.
- What do female
performers do when they get
their periods?
- For work?
Makeup sponges.
- What is that?
- So you know the thing that's squishy,
that you use to apply
foundation on your face?
Shove that up your cooter.
- So I want to know,
what is the greatest
number of times you've
orgasm'd in a day?
- 26 in an hour,
and then I didn't count the rest,
'cause it was like, a
challenge by a cam member.
♫ A dick in your mouth
♫ There was a dick in your mouth
♫ It was rather big and veiny
♫ I was surprised
♫ And kind of not
♫ You did cry the first time we had sex
♫ I said don't you worry
♫ You look like your hands are full
♫ Just kidding
♫ Just your mouth ♫